THE PAR CONNUESN FLODA
CONGRESSN SLWELEING THELAST LIB
STATE. IN T NDATFREE
Tod JOE CCHA HE TO
IGHIN.
ALWE LIVNECESSAR ONE OF
CAFORN.POPAR HIDAY DEINATNS,IBA
Y WLD HE FLY HIS FAMY
ROSS COURY T THATORBLE
NOOOD CSERVIVE STAFFLIDA?
>> J: TT I T THI IF Y
E CONGSSWON FRO N
ANDANUARY BAUSE O ICE ANDOUTF N
SN AND CDND WIND AND SO
ON.IF I AEADYM LIVINGN
LIFOIA AND BIE MEANDS
SA,A HOYAMABU,OU HE
IF Y WT T TE YRKIDS TO
DIEY RLD, THE II
WHY GOO FLORA?SWWELLOES TT PERPK
ON GO INTO AESTAANT WITHOUT
OFFERI VACNE RD, MAY
ITFEELS LIK AACATN MORN
ORIDA TN I CALIFORA A
SPEA VOLUMS FAR AS
MOCRIC WMAK AER
GRETCHENHITM SAI N TOO
TOLORI BAUSE OACCI
NMANTES.
WE WIL G YREAIONN THEIFOR
OTHE DE
SUOSEDO DO, ITOESN SP OMRON,HAT
TH A VAAN IT TS STRGERAN DOEDIF.
>>shley:WO THGS.
I DON'T WAN TO TE MIC
VIROM WOPGOERG,AN
WETOP CALNG THIS PDEMIFTH UNVAI
FECTG T VACCINAD AND
VACCINAT, Y HAV BN
VING UER A ROCK.
Tod YEA A WOPIAID
THIS VIANTSSTRONGERHE
TA SWS I IS WKER ASAR
ALITY TOILL PEOE OR
SPITIZ PELE.
ITSOREONTAOUS THAN
LTA, BUTERTALYOT
SOMEINGTRONR IN TERMS OF
ABITYO MAK YOU SI.
MAYBHOOP TOOHE PSIDE
HIS WORD WN HEOLDNN
TOWN HL LT YE, OU ARE
T GNG TOET COV I YOU
HAVECCINATIO," AND WHOI
TTIN CIDHOWS NO PSO
OULDLAIMGAS M BEN
DIDGAIN THIS VIR CAN B
OPPE OR NTAID.
W YORK TY,OR EXPLE,
MARKLE NUER, TY AREAVAGIN 40,00
PERAY DPITE T FT 85% OF
TH CITOPULION RECEID O
SEFHE VAINE, HHLY
VAINAT CI.
4000 CASESERY.
YOU KWHAT NEWORK WAS
AVERAGG AEAR A WN NO O
WA VACNATE OUTSIDEF
ALTHRE RKER
LESS.CES PER DAY,IX TIS
TH VARIANTS HIGY
CONTIOUS W NEE TOALK LES
ERAPEUCS AIVING WHTINGOMENDOREB
COD THROU TREMENTND
GOG ABOUT OURAILY LIV
RTICULAR WHE ITCOS T SCOLS.
I HOEOPLE I CHICAGORE
WATCNG W.
Tod SOUNDSIKEOMEBY IS
JOE NCHA, TNKS F BEI
WI US GEUR BESOOUR
FE.
Joe: A D'TRINK CFEE
OU